what is going on there citizens of the reject
Nation rejoined but my man the real Aaron
Alexander right now because we're gonna watch
One Piece episode two if you didn't catch her
reaction to episode one that is up here on
the channel really really enjoyed the heck
out of that first episode I change it to the
sweater because I felt like color scheme wise
it kind of feels like one piece a little bit
it does it's like wow it's very easy oh it's
thin too oh my God you look below me on these
guys highly recommend you can use your promo
code too it's not an ad for them but I guess it
is please go ahead leave a like on this video
that would mean a lot also subscribe click
that notification Bell we don't really know
the pattern of when these videos will be going
up but just do it so that way you get notified
when episode three is up here on the channel
and as always thank you to all who have joined
our patreon page full-length Reaction watch
along We sync up with their own copy of One
Piece available for a super sexy rejects we also
covers several shows exclusively over there the
reaction highlights and watch along this included
some anime over there we did not watch the anime
of one piece so this is all fresh experience
for us and it has been very very enjoyable
thus far and thank you again to prep for having
to set it down these highlights let's get to it
[Music]
you want trouble you just found it
little boy Luffy racially ambiguous Luffy
I can fix it interesting how
there's no like opening credits
yeah right the animes are notorious
for that no two are the same
there's a reason they call devil fruits oh so
there's other people who've had Devil's fruits
who are out there you know this kid looks like
a younger version of the person who plays gravic
in secret oh my God totally I see it when will
you be back we're not coming back what rutro she
said that's so apathetically I told you I need an
absolute silence I know I know it's just that 3D
dude me too and can you please
give me some quiet and some space
I don't even need to stretch
for that one it's not cool
before he left he gave him his hat that's
important to me did you knock it off
I'm trying to take a nap oh I'm sorry
were we interrupting your beauty sleep
now he's like a weighted blanket a neck pillow
sleeping mask the whole shebang AC [Laughter]
ID ah she's good she's good at what she does
isn't this supposed to be cold inside a safe
it's knowledge this is a map to the Grand
line I'd take the gold over knowledge any day
hahaha a shortcut past the knowledge
but the gold nugget is by the knowledge [Laughter]
thin strip of land that circles the glow
it's called the red line it's banned across
the middle is the grand line a treacherous
stretch of ocean with bigger islands and if
you fold that poke a pencil through it
it becomes a wormhole yeah the Marines
wow great shooting
sleeping gas red sleeping gas swallow
it no no way I know a lot of women who
can do that trick you know what I mean
Luffy can take pipes circus performers
clever I like it put on a t-shirt I'm so glad this
show is enjoyable it sucks when you
commit to a show it's not a joyful
anime things are going to be mad
it took 200 episodes to get to
the point let's get so much damn it we've lost
safe place a lot of these like interesting angles
with the handheldness that really follow
the motion of the performers yeah [Music]
oh yes
prisoners having to be pretend to be audience
it's all wrong Spotlight was late you completely
missed my entrance that guy looks so familiar
oh my God that's a different Agents of Shield
you're the clown guy um buggy buggy the Clown
buggy the genius Jester wow you have a lot
of names everyone knows who you are [Music]
okay go bring up the nose sensitive about
his nose I've been scheming for months
steal that map from old ax hand
only to find out that I was upstaged
by three little nobodies nose buddies I'm Monkey D
Luffy and I will be king of the Pirates now that's
wow this is disorienting as hell
feels like a Rob Zombie movie
I can't reward them with that man I suppose
I'll have to offer them a pound of Flesh
Instead This guy's kind of frustrating what
if I give you a new freak for your crew
I'm gonna offer up Luffy with his
little stretchy powers hey [Music]
that was messed up ah dang
left their ass are they on land
oh my God the set is crazy
wow why would you stop silent Runners what did
you do to their town you destroyed everything
everything I let him keep their hands
relax you're being dramatic okay so he is a
sadistic man oh yeah of course classic clowns
I'm gonna have a chat with my stretchy New Pal
his nose has um follicles what is it well his
nose doesn't look like some attachment it looks
like it's a real look like deformity thing yeah
yeah it has pores on it there you go yeah of
course they wouldn't have gotten away in the first
place if my useless son had been able to prevent
their escape do you think the sun might become
a good guy at some point not with that haircut
nearly enlisted just this morning sir you think
so sounds gonna be good I'm not sure it could go
either way huh saw a town or what was left of one
after Bucky destroyed it I mean when he tried to
run off and leave us for dead I know your type
but there's nothing to gain you're out it says
the wandering Bounty Hunter oh we are setting
up character arcs here you have a lock pick I
have four lock picks clowns only found three
oh sheesh oh that is cruel hey give me back
my hat I used to know a pirate that wore a
hat just like this Ginger three scars left eye we
serve together oh the pirate crew did he kill him
until he betrayed me he wanted to keep my star
from shining too brightly young of the Hat
don't talk about him that way finally getting
to the truth stretch him until he breaks
don't they say in prison I'm
warning you it's Bucky [Applause]
there he is there's all this
body horror element to this
[Music] whoa he punched his head off I did
not see that's coming yo he punched his head
off hi what ah CGI head and he's alive
you have something else in common what
the hell he had one of the devil's these fruit
oh shoot the chop chop fruit always put myself
back together again whoa it's like the detachable
kit it's detachable kid yeah TDK oh oh yep oh no
okay all right that was pretty cool because I was
like ah this guy's kind of getting on my nerves
he's a little Annoying like he's supposed to be
yeah now I'm like okay now he's a real threat yeah
I've been thinking about you for
years but how you killed my brother
oh followed us for weeks through the swamplands
does he not recall you cut off his
head you stuffed it in a bag all for
a few buried okay that does sound like
me let's see if you can keep your head
it's cool they really put the actor on that yeah
pick that look we both know you don't but being
a marine until I've ever wanted and I want to
believe you but it's not out for a guy makes
father makes a choice for himself but it just gets
stuck here how long have you been working with a
pirate to attack this base I was held captive by
a pirate named alvido so he saved me don't say his
name Lucy ah damn it you're rat immediately ratted
him out could have made up the name any name
could have said lofi you could have said lofty
waffy son and why didn't you tell anyone about
this I was worried they wouldn't let me enlist
telling the truth is a core value of the Marines
you could have just slid the chair with your hands
had to be extra with it can't be a marine unless
you're dramatic do you owe him any Allegiance
Hearts should face Justice dude
and we'll find him together
that's conflicting that sucks immediately
rants him out I'll act so like freaking
terrified every step he takes every move
he makes I thought the [__] was supposed
to be popular oh he's gonna kick some ass kick
some booty come on Luffy put a fist in his ass
okay you wanna talk like a man you
better be ready to back it up lucky man
you're lucky I don't slit his throat you
can spill a drink on me and I'll let it
slide but don't you ever threaten
my friends [Music] oh I love this
oh nice Steve's actual superpower you ever
see that Trope before yeah yeah [Laughter]
all right here we go
nice creative as hell [Music]
dude's got style great fight love this nice man
for pirates that don't resort
to violence this is awesome
only when absolutely necessary I
love the presence of These Guys
these guys are awesome what
a dope crew where's Luffy
oh nice shot
I was a really good upside down reveal because
it looked like he might have been underwater
like yeah it's like have a dip underwater
already it's kind of confusing so it puts
you in the state of mind he's in that was
really well done don't bother it's seawater
all those wonderful powers rendered useless
from a few splashes see water's a weakness I
guess so see water is his crib tonight
is it that way for all people who use
or is it just a kind of water it is I really want
to know if the water is the weakness you said
seawater specifically yeah imagine if he drinks
water I'm sure he's fine I will find one piece
and then everyone will know my name and they'll
love me you just want acceptance poor Arthur
Fleck Chase is gonna grind you up and make banded
sausage they're nowhere you can hide you really
think anyone is coming for you this guy looks
very familiar same yeah it's a tavier Arbor them
what the hell yeah the city Beast
Sea Beast love me a good Sea Beast
how inconvenient is that he's a
pirate who obviously Travels by
sea yeah and his he's always
surrounded by his weakness
shanks
this is Shanks have a a power oh no
okay but he can work with the CPS
we see it oh damn holy [__] that's a
face that is awesome oh my God that's
scary those red eyes oh my god [Music]
get lost oh he does have a power yeah
oh excellent what a cool design
yeah right I wonder if that's
what looks in the anime I wonder
if it's gonna come back into play
later on probably you know just
one and done an animal like that
oh my God it's my fault oh does he bleed out from
this I'm just glad that you're okay wow you don't
look like you're in pain at all dude yeah he's
a man man men don't feel pain I would be like I
regret it saving your ass immediately I really
don't fear death do you no just don't fear you
nice tempting as it sounds I'm not sticking
around got somewhere else to be didn't used
to think so but Luffy changed that don't tell
me you actually believe in him I don't need to
he believes in himself rubs off and
one more thing don't turn around
[Music]
kind of works like a boomerang in a way oh God
my hat mapper the Hat mapper the Hat
oh wow just let them take the map huh he
won't get away with it you want a piece of me
cool fascinating
oh my God what the hell how do you kill
a guy like that I mean I think you if you
just like drown him if you capture if
bag is head you can at least trap him
guys
it's kind of wild what a Whimsical last scenario
to be in right looks really good though yeah
great ass effects great effects African
dump sea water on me and I'll let it slide
but don't miss my friends but don't you ever
threaten my friends yup yup or my hat [Music] oh
clap that head what the hell
job [Applause] Cannon this is an anime
no no not the Hat how could you
not me the crates yeah
trap him nice that makes sense
it's cool it's a fun game
bastard what have you done to me that's identifice
3D
I can't wait for Zorro to call out his power
right oh let's move we are new captors what
aren't you I'm a different kind of pirate yep
yep look at him even they're feeling their
heroism as well hero pirate the men and
women of this base have not failed
the Marines but their leadership has
we can take their ships their weapons
and even their lives but we cannot win
if we do not take away their dreams oh
[__] personally leading a mission to
hunt down the Pirates Who attack this
base and I am taking this Squadron of
new Cadets with me you want to start with
the new cadets for justice for the Marines
for Sparta okay now now I really think he's
gonna have a different turn the sun yeah I
don't think he's gonna turn to help Luffy
I think he's gonna turn in his own interest
s you needed more than we do what do you guys
eat let me take any food he eats Maps [Laughter]
some maps and metal maybe just a snack yeah
none for my friends just I'm a hungriest I was
I was held captive underwater thank you all
for your hospitality and the food and the
drink we'll savor it as long as we can and
with lucky rude that should be about three hours
interesting how his he's not just mirroring him
his his life is really playing out like a
pattern that truly emulates us hmm he's a
hero pirate inspired by the best I miss you
most of all no faith you were right shanks
back when you wouldn't let me join your crew
oh this is when he gets the Hat I'm gonna be
a pirate Captain I'm gonna find the one piece
and become king of the Pirates in that case
oh I'm invested [Laughter]
and I want you to take it I want you
to meet him again one day as an adult
[Music]
you can give it back to me only after you
become a great pirate I'll be our promise
oh oh I guess one day they will reunite
yeah 1 000 live action episodes from now
14 years that was really sweet now
growing to a Latino boy with the
power of this hat I will develop an accent [Music]
almost finished oh she's helping hmm what's her
name again her name is daughter of guy from the
beginning Shanks always said that is the path
to what you want seems too easy then you're on
the wrong path what [Laughter] gotta take the
hard route that's what makes it worth it next
next the ground line
I like this guy if you have ulterior motives girl
a grinder
a little oh she's communicating you little
spy hello Spy Girl she's been communicating
that's crazy it's me you can tell them
I have the map what no Bluetooth Trader
[Music]
oh
you lady
can't trust her damn damn damn let's look up her
name before we talk at all what's that girls well
I'll look it up while you're talking what did
you think of the episode I thought it was a lot
of fun I liked it and I liked it whatever you're
gonna say until I was gonna say no I don't think
I was gonna say as much as the first episode
I don't know because I think now we're finally
into the adventure and I think even though this
is like a 40 plus minute episode it felt like
an episode of a an anime like it felt like a
piece a chapter in a show but I also have the
episodic kind of feel like a villain of the week
kind of thing with uh with Bugsy here yeah yeah
um but yeah I thought it was a lot of fun I like
getting to see them Bond a little bit more learn
a bit a little bit more about Luffy's past and
his powers I will say the at first I wasn't as
interested in the the Marine stuff but now we
see all the pieces coming together I'm like oh
where is this heading and yeah I'm starting to
really Vibe with this crew you know like Zorro
cool as a cucumber always her name is Nami Nami I
thought so I thought her name was Nami uh but yeah
I really like the the way that it was shot too oh
yeah I would keep telling Luffy we could just call
them the funky no I don't think no one's called
him monkey I think he's only referred to himself
as monkeys he's way easier to remember Monkey D
you're gonna call Monkey D yeah Monkey D Monkey D
uh so yeah Monkey D he's continues to be
charismatic I'm not gonna call Monkey D Luffy is
yeah you know I think the show has a lot of heart
so far in addition to being exciting and this wash
buckling Adventure like you can tell that this
is something that's full of heart and even though
I've only seen these two episodes I can tell that
it has a spirit of anime and this is probably why
a lot of people love it because like dang this
show has so much hurt and even towards the end
where you see uh the relationship between Shanks
and Luffy and how he finally got his hat and like
the sacrifice that he did to save Luffy like the
the relationship and how important that guy is to
our lead our main character yeah and it makes
me like dang I really want to see like what's
going to happen between all these characters how
are these lines going to converge and yeah who I
really want him to get to the Grand line because
like this kid has so much heart he believes in
himself and you see the impact of this kid's
energy and how it affects the people around him
because he is so positive and yet so powerful but
isn't like egotistical about it he's just a good
person and yeah I'm thoroughly enjoying this um
I don't know how far down the line the stuff with
with Shanks this is something from the beginning
is is this something that's you know revealed
towards the end because you know how animes are
like 22 minutes long so and they take like forever
to reveal information so I don't know but um yeah
I liked it I'm not getting the impression though
that this feel this like to me off of course
constant reminder we haven't seen the anime
it doesn't get I don't get the impression it's
like I I'll watch other adaptations and stuff and
I really get the impression of this and I don't
get and I don't feel this when I watch it that
I'm watching something that feels like it's been
overly condensed or that oh wow this needs more
breathing room or they're rushing this you know
like I don't have any of those opinions about it
uh I yeah I like the first episode more there are
things about this and of course you continue on
the journey you expand upon that make me like
characters like the what this what this did was
make me like the main characters significantly
more even though I already like them a lot
um I just that feeling has now been enhanced
and I agree with you about the Marine quality
too of like okay yeah this is much more
interesting I like the Dilemma that it puts
that kid that kid the bow is his name I
don't know his name here with the pink
here I don't know yeah I don't know any
of these names look familiar to you is
it alvita no maybe click on him let's click on
it and we got the IMDb fold up here nope yeah
what is that Kobe it's Kobe it's Kobe right
yeah yeah it's Kobe yep it is Kobe yes
I remember doing the Kobe but um yeah that
part wasn't as interesting because every time
they got to that no nobody is an evil dead rise
yeah I know you haven't seen that that's right
couldn't piece it together um okay so yeah uh
I like the Dilemma that it puts Kobe in because
um it I think there could be a debate that happens
there of like oh is this something that you know
as I can see the reaction that someone might
have of like you snitched too early damn you
um but they've established the character well
enough that it's he's such a frightened dude
yeah that is he's just gonna be he naturally he's
go uh it makes sense that the pat that how he got
pushed into this corner you know what I mean like
it makes complete sense to me that that he would
actually unveil that and it does make for an
interesting conflict of The Journey he might
go on because you could see him going down like
paths that do cause more resistance and put him
more into not quite antagonists but an obstacle
that our Trio has to fight against you know or
could be the path where he's he ends up you
know becoming so disillusioned by the Marines
uh Conquest I hope that's the path that goes
downwards like this is not what all what I thought
it was going to be and then decides to help out
either way I think the performer is doing a really
good job because if the performer wasn't so good
I wouldn't have been I wouldn't have bought that
as much I might have been a little bit annoyed by
the choice yeah you feel you feel bad for the guy
you know and he's in a compromising position
and he's just afraid he's trying to make it
through and I imagine he joined the Marines
because in spite of all this fear that he has
inside of him he wants to do the right thing he
wants to yeah someone who who is courageous and
you know maybe he's on the wrong side of things
right now but I hope for the development of him
that he gets that courageousness inside of him
you know and what I like to or what this episode
established really well when you compare it to
Something Like Pirates of the Caribbean which is
you know like oh the Pirates there's the the the
the the the the criminals but you never really get
the sensitivity of the bad guys yeah you know like
they have like bad pirates in there who are going
up against other Pirates and but you still they
still make the pirate life like they it hones in
so much on the Fantastical side of the Pirates and
the pirates only really seem to be an issue for
like other pirates in that franchise you know
what I mean where here would I like what they
did with buggy I got kind of like things that I
liked about bugging and things that didn't what
I like that they did with buggy was was like him
and his crew and and the way they were torturing
this town how they wrecked their whole town and
then they were enslaving the people they really
showed the truly Sinister villainous side of
pirates so it's not just also show showcasing
that hey you know like our band of Misfits are
pirates and the seasons and pirate life glorious
like yeah there's the fun side of it too the
fantasy side of that but they're also showing
us now there really is like a really messed
up side too so I love that they included that
um and I of course I I love the the power
set of buggy and I I'm ex I wonder if every
villain we encounter with superpower is all
going to be Devil's fruit oh maybe yeah yeah
some type of Link there what I and maybe
it is like oh it's an accurate depiction of
um of what buggy is like in the anime or something
like maybe it is I didn't ultimately feel
like when you when you do the setup of what
buggy looks like and and like clown pirate
it went the performance like it's weird where
my conflict comes in is I feel like the actor
who played buggy did a good job with the
material like he completely serviced it
but I didn't feel like there was anything
TR that it was exactly the the path that
you would expect based off of oh yeah
clown pirate guy I didn't really feel
like there was anything that unique
to it um specifically his portrayal
not the way you portrayed it but the depiction
of of what this character is that I I felt like
there could have been something that was a little
bit more fresh about it so he so he actually came
down to being like kind of a frustrating thing
for me to watch a little Annoying and not super
entertaining or even scary you know and I could
have used that for how much Focus as there was
on him I think it's funny because I remember
uh saying earlier on I was like oh it's not
the performance isn't bothering me because I'm
used to watching this actor which I now know his
name is Jeff Ward uh and I think that as the
episode continued I became not conflicted but
I held two feelings at the same time one was
like I enjoy watching the soccer perform in
this goofy role because I've liked him in other
things but the same hand watching the character
itself I think that and Grant I don't have the
anime to compare against that it could have he
didn't come across as threatening to me I was
never like afraid or thought this guy was like
crazy or anything I mean he obviously he was
crazy but I'm never like whoa this guy's freaking
nuts I never felt threatened by him and I think
maybe part of that was the performance as well
um yeah I just I thought the effects on him
were really cool don't get me wrong I thought
that was that stuff was awesome but maybe like a
little bit more unhinged slash threatening like
when he was telling them to like laugh or like you
know don't laugh like I didn't get the sense that
outside of having these guys have powers that
his Aura and of itself was something that was
threatening or scary yeah that's a good way to
put it yeah you said it much better than me yeah
I think like the power should make him scary
the guys should make him scary and then the
powers are the the icing on top of the fact that
he's scary yeah you know I think if they would
have utilized or lean into the the clown aspect
of him more and then how that power thing being
enhanced on the the clown thing I think that
would have worked a lot better so like maybe
this guy was miscast I mean I like the actor but
yeah we'll see what they go what they do with him
um but yeah I think ultimately that's what
I walked away feeling I thought the fights
are really cool the powers were really dope you
know and especially like because I could easily
have turned into like ridiculous like dumb
goofy territory but I I don't know if it's
the fact that the effects were good or they the
story and characters were good or the fact that
I don't know I just think all of it together
worked when it easily could have gone into like
this is Goofy dumb territory like maybe the
knowledge that it's based on the anime maybe
helps that a little bit but yeah overall the that
fight scene really worked for me yeah loud hyper
sensitive really just insecure clown yeah like
I feel like I've seen this like a billion times
yeah and it was this little it was a little it
was a little it was only annoying because it was
so much of the episode you know and I liked what
it did for our other characters though you know um
like it spoke volumes to me when uh uh monkey D's
hat got stabbed and I really felt that I was like
[__] [__] it's good because the show did such
a great job on emphasizing Yeah by illustrating
that whenever this guy's usually in a chipper
mood or in a a a a ponderous or eager mood and
time he gets serious is when you mess with
the hat or his friends that was established
after like they really made it clear like he
this mood switches when you mess with his hat
and and how much that meets him and the show's
been doing such a good job at showing us like
where it comes from and you don't really know
yet what the history is but clearly he has a
much such an emotional attachment I'm attached
to Monkey D so when the Hat got stabbed I was
like oh I was like I've never felt that with a
an item like just getting struck good like that
it's like an animal okay you know like something
like that and he punctured it you know and they
put so much emphasis too that's like an old hat
you know and I'm like oh damn so I thought they
they added such great weight with that and I guess
sea water does that is the weakness as if through
swallowing or it seems like it's just dipping
him yeah yeah just putting him in it weakens him
um and maybe that's the way forever because
he because it seemed like he really knew that
the yeah he said like don't bother it's uh
seawater and and for buggy to just know that
and the way he kind of threw that line out
there would mean that buggy would also be
um prone to being vulnerable to that as well
yeah yeah yeah because he recognized as soon
as he stretched oh he's he's bitten the same
type of fruit that I have so by then wouldn't
know what his weakness is which is interesting
because it makes me the more we watch it that
makes me more curious about the lore behind
this world like what is the deal with these
fruits like where is Shanks and his his people
you know what is going on with with Zorro in
his history and what is this Grand line which
Granite we'll find out eventually whether it's
the end of the season or 400 episodes from now
do you think there's going to be a romance with
Zorro I I got the that that chemistry that that
butting heads kind of chemistry from those two
so well I feel like Nami you're supposed to she's
supposed to have that duplicitous quality to her
like I don't know which side is she on but I
think ultimate she's gonna be on the good side
yeah yeah especially toward that thing at the
end when they're using their snail Bluetooth
maybe maybe it's not as bad as it looks maybe
that's just the Cliffhanger they left us on I mean
she's she has to be communicating with that one
guy which guy the guy the the head of the [__]
um gang of the Marines oh you think she's with
working with the Marines GARP was the only one
remember at the end of episode one he's the
one who talked on the snail phone and then
we heard the incoming we couldn't hear
who was on the other end oh and then and
then when she was making the sounds with it
that was it was the exact same sounds so I
think the implication is that she's the
one communicating with with the head of
the Marines oh okay she was a little traitor a
little traitor girl okay I could see that yeah
but why but why though because why would she why
would she bother to steal it it doesn't yeah it
doesn't make any sense it doesn't make sense I
can see it but it's not line enough the math I
mean I guess that it might be a mislead because
she keeps saying how much she hates Pirates I feel
like it's a myth mislead but I mean we don't know
how she feels about Marines I mean she did kind of
take some of them down so I don't know if she has
more at play than just that um but no everything's
good and I like the way how you're seeing Zorro
starting uh lighting up too you know uh but yeah
everything's great right now all right well six
more episodes to go we don't know when episode
three will be coming out I got working on Aaron's
stupid schedule with this other job I got nine to
five I got nine to five is not a consistent nine
to five I can work with a consistent nine to five
it's a really you would be here at 6 p.m and then
we would figure it out my job loves consistency
alrighty guys thanks for being here and we'll
catch you all soon peace out reject Nation [Music]